what would you say to some people that  are one trick point is to see if they  can improve themselves every year to  recreate themselves  so the one trick pony is two two-part  question  if you're super successful at being the  one-trick pony is all saying in the hood  if it ain't broke don't fix it  right  so now if you're a one trick pony if  you're super  sickness but now if you're a one-trick  pony and it doesn't work you gotta  expand your horizons pretty good point  so if I'm if I'm playing Power  basketball that didn't work now I gotta  go to finesse  like if I've got power that don't work  Finance don't work now I got to forget  about offense focus on defense set picks  Buckshot so you always have to expand  because we want to maximize our  potential we want to be the best and you  know you could you could play like this  at a certain level but at some point  you're gonna have to make that change to  stay successful